but first labor were of course hoping to
make some big gains on Thursday night
building on their success in the 2017
general election but the party's
performance fell short of their own
perhaps overly inflated expectations and
the man responsible for that election
strategy is party chairman in Lavery who
joins us now live from New Castle thanks
for being with us today good morning
I hope um I used to get rid of that fly
before the interview let's talk as well
as always it just come right on your
nose a and just as the program starts it
seems to alone now now let's talk about
the local election shall we labor one
just 78 more councilors ended up
unchanged in terms of councils were you
disappointed by those results we if you
look back I mean we've we've not only
consolidated at the local elections
we've we've mud in advances we'll if you
look back Yasuo fee it's only 14 months
where the Labour Party was some twenty
four percentage points behind in the
polls and then leading up to the snap
election we were just behind the
Conservatives following the the general
election and the results which we had on
Thursday were an improvement by probably
somewhere in the region of 2.5 percent
which brought the the Labour Party
neck-and-neck with the Conservatives so
although we didn't have massive gains as
perhaps was projected by the
conservative central office we we were a
happy enough to see that we didn't stand
still and we move forward and we believe
there's much much more to come by that
we're much much more to come you see I
can't work out genuinely if you're
trying to put a positive spin on things
fair enough that's your job or if you
really think that these results are in
advance they really are something to be
pleased about well the it isn't spend
it's factually correct and I've
mentioned the the statistics begin by
about two and a half percentage points
on Thursday and if you look at John
Curtis the reknowned
coolest he said on on
that if we replicated the the results on
Thursday the the actual virtue they in
the Labor Party would be in government
now we would be the biggest party in the
country and the Conservatives would be
we're behind they would lose 30 30 odd
seats so we've got to look at that as
being a positive only 14 months ago
people were suggesting that we were
fierce and annihilation and that if the
party had nowhere else to go so we are
quite pleased with that we've met some
advances on Thursday we met advances in
London and let us just say sube the fact
that the Conservative headquarters
central office predicted through the the
media that there would be a Tory wipeout
in London there weren't our projections
there weren't our predictions we wanted
to have a good result in London we got a
very good result in the the constant
races in London and we're quite quite
pleased with that
well it's not just the Conservatives
talking about a conservative white part
in London was it I mean Sadiq Khan said
there's now no corner of London where
labour can't win Jeremy Corbyn launched
the Labour campaign from Westminster I
mean it wasn't just the Conservatives
who expecting to do better in London you
were as well well we did do better in
London that we'll look at ones with for
example ones worse we the Conservative
headquarter suggested that we would win
that easy
that's where territories Aamir went to
on Friday mornings you hold on to the
flagship of one's back by a very
fingertips but when you look and just
dig a little bit and look at the
statistics the Labour Party got the the
popular vote it was backed by more than
two end ones worth sorry by more than
2,000 votes we got that we got good
results in a lot of the the constituency
ously the wards with in Wandsworth we
actually we actually won seven seats
huge strides forward in Wandsworth and
we only fell short of Teague and
Wandsworth council by roughly one
hundred and
41 votes listen that cannot be sniffed
out it's huge progress this is the
flagship council if the Tory party this
is such as big flagship if the
Conservatives for generations we were
only a whisker away from chin ones worth
that's not something we should be
disappointed at it's something we will
build on and will take forward and I
think we've got a bright future and
those those awards those contingencies
in in London in particular but it wasn't
just London look at what happened in
traffic for example we took the the
traffic council the last blue Tory blue
flagship in Greater Manchester in the
northwest we took that from Tory the
Nova no overall control from the Tories
the Labour Party being the biggest party
in Trafford what a brilliant success we
want Plymouth we want Kirklees we took
control of Tower Hamlets we had a a
reasonable night despite the fact that
the press would like this here that it
was an immeasurably poor night for the
Labour Party at the same time it seems
to me looking at these results that what
you're seeing is stasis the
Conservatives doing well in the kind of
suburbs and the Shires labour piling up
votes in places like Trafford in places
like London not really breaking through
outside the areas that you already feel
quite comfortable in what you're saying
it doesn't seem like there's much
soul-searching going on as to why that
is are you actually learning any lessons
from the results of Sophie let me let me
tell you that the the conclusion of any
election whether it be local elections
or whether it would be a by-election or
whether it would be the general
elections that the party in most parties
do the sium have a complete or a
post-mortem into what happened in the
different areas in the different regions
and will be doing exactly the same and
we will be learning yes because people
make mistakes and we will be learning
from the that what actually happened
during the campaign and in 2018 but it's
not not as negative as what people are
some people who like the portrait we
have met an advancement of somewhere in
the
2.5% if we can replicate that in the
next two or three years from the general
election will be on 47 48 percentage
points that would be enough to win a
general election okay now I want to talk
about Barnett and on paper it should
have been one of your easiest targets of
course then fell short there and there
was this anti Semitism Rao which many
people feel it cost you that council now
this morning's car news spoke to Adam
Langevin who was a Labour councillor who
lost her seat in that area and we asked
him if he had a question to put to you
to put to the Labour leadership what
would you want to say so let's just
listen to that it's not Smith I'd say he
needs to come to Barnett seats and meet
with Jewish community wasn't just bonus
actually is also hiring Gaye and
Manchester and Liverpool we lost in any
area which had large numbers of Jewish
people and they need to really engage
these understand fill the pain that
people feel that I thought that my
family feel that the Labour Party the
party that a Jewish community helped
build a hundred years ago has all of a
sudden turned on the Jewish community
and that is so painful and I don't think
they I don't think people and at the top
of they party quite recognize how
painful this is for so many people in
the Jewish community now Adam believes
the elements at the Labor Party have a
problem weird racism is he right I think
in the Labour Party those a that has
been a problem with unti Semitism
there's a problem with racism with with
all forms of of bully and harassment and
intimidation we'll route that out let me
make it clear to Adam and all these cult
colleagues we will again integrate
within the Jewish community we will make
this right we will put this right
there'll be massive discussions and lots
of intense discussions with the Jewish
community we've met with the Board of
Deputies except only a couple of weeks
ago then discussions will continue and
on my heart goes out to the likes of
Adam and others in the Jewish
communities who will put a lot into the
Labor Party and yes many of them
councillors that is me and not have been
returned within that constituency's who
we've lost consensus because of what
happened in in the the row on
anti-semitism
we'll put this right we've got a new
general secretary Jenny formed me
Jenny's got this at the top of her
political agenda anti-semitism has no
rule nucleus at all in the Liberal Party
we will root it out from top to bottom
of that is a chairman of the party I can
categorically tell you strong message
out there from your own anti-semitism I
wonder if you'll be equally strong in
another area where it feels as though
labor
perhaps slipped behind expectations and
that's in areas that voted to leave the
European Union do you think that Labor's
stance on brexit remaining in the
customs union is damaging the party in
some of those areas that voted leave
well against Sophie it's a mixed bag we
look at the the Midlands of course you
were really disappointing results the
leave areas in the Midlands the that the
working-class white working-class areas
and we've got a challenge here look at
the Northeast where we are at this
moment of time hugely again leave area
where are we cleared you know we clean
the floors basically totally red we gain
seats in in in different constituencies
in the Northeast so there's a whole
mishmash with regards to the issue of
brexit what the Labour Party is
absolutely adamant we stand clear by
what we see it in our manifesto we want
a brexit which secures jobs the economy
and a whole number of other things we
also said that we will were happy with
the transitional period during that
transitional period what we will do is
abide by the customs union under single
Martlet rules and following that we
would want a deal on a customs union and
a deal on the single market is will and
of course it's very very difficult as a
party where you've got diverse views but
listen it's not the only party with
problems with regards to the the the
brexit situation the Conservatives are
tearing themselves apart early this
morning in the press you can see the
attacks from the brexit tears and the
remain as both groups are seeing that
Tahrir Zamir must adhere to what they
say all the war
now she's got a multitude of problems
fierce in her as a prime minister we're
looking at the city we should we're
absolutely crystal clear on where we
stand with regards to breakfast